got this girlfriend we've been dating
for about four years she has a brother
he's 27 I'm 26 I'm 6'2 he's 59 but
regardless um he's over affectionate
with my girlfriend and it needs to be
stopped and I don't know what to say or
what to do every time we meet up uh he
gives her like a big hug and a forehead
kiss and he has a pet name for her he
calls her Mumu he says I missed you
MooMoo uh and then he's like
overprotective and oh that's he just
whines about the weirdest things towards
her uh when we leave he gives another
forehead kiss and a bye MooMoo um but
the other day we were on the boat me my
girlfriend her brother and the dad and
he ate a [__] we were all tuckered out
at the end of the day her brother was
off doing something so we just said bye
to the dad and we kept pushing um maybe
an hour or two later we get a call from
the Dad that says her brother's so
pissed off why that she didn't say bye
to him oh no he didn't get his precious
by moooo forehead kiss and that's really
what threw me over the edge but here's
the
caveat he's such a sensitive guy and the
dad is such a sensitive guy and the mom
is such a sensitive lady so I can't make
things too awkward because they'll never
talk to me again like if I I can't
properly just call them out and say hey
big dogs around no more
forehead no more MooMoo we're all adults
here uh I can't really do that in a too
aggressive way I don't know what to say
any advice would be appreciated again
love you guys what an interesting thing
R yeah it does I I wonder what she
thinks well that's what I was going to
say talk to your girl and ask her or not
ask her don't [__] foot around it just
be like say Big Dog's around listen
you're look look you're talking to big
dog right now okay it's just you and big
dog
okay look it's just you and big dog so
we can just you know we don't have to
[__] each other okay big dog don't
[__] okay
and do how do you in all honesty how do
you feel with like the level of
affection your brother displays for you
and the we like the overprotectiveness
that he displays hey look look it's me
it's just big dog and Mumu face to face
big dog and Mumu okay I'm your brother
right now imagine I'm your brother and
then get down like this like real like
low you know cuz he's 5'9 like first of
all how does he get well she's probably
shorter yeah um just be like do you like
the forehead kisses do are you momu or
are you my girl right maybe she doesn't
like it the the pet name thing I don't
who cares I was going to say that's not
a thing I mean siblings call each other
[__] like that all the time yeah yeah I
call that weakling I call him boa bang
bang bing bing weakling and boo bang
bang bing bing uh but um no bully you
know
weakling so dumb and an alien Bing
binging Bing um but I don't
uh you know the forehead
kiss that's kind of odd that it's always
a forehead kiss to me age it's one thing
if you're just I don't care about that
but like that's a weird it almost that
makes it feel like it's a weird
ownership thing or something or
definitely some sort of insecurity thing
I don't know but um the overly sensitive
thing is is terrible I mean you're just
being a big just being a person big dog
and if you were to just say yo it makes
me uncomfortable
the way they're treated and then it was
fine but what do you mean he's pissed
off that she didn't say bye sometimes
you just don't say bye to somebody ever
heard of Irish people and like you know
like it's okay you know not you don't be
like get over it but like we're all
adults big dogs around and it's
fine yeah uh I think that for for him to
say I don't want to make a big deal it
because they're never going to talk to
me again is that that's crazy people in
her family are clearly way too sensitive
okay now obviously you want to
accommodate for that as much as you can
cuz it's they're your girlfriend's
family you love your girl but at a
certain point you cannot continue to
accommodate someone like that like you
or a group of people like that you
can't you can't you're big dog dude you
can't constantly be Shackled if you're
big dog you can't big dogs do not you
can't be Shackled too much right not
yeah exactly you you're going to break
free of those chains eventually because
you're big dog yep if you're big dog you
got to be the big dog unfortunately it's
your nature yeah so I mean it sounds
like you can at least take a few steps
first to avoid a potential confrontation
first and and obvious and I'm I'm
stunned if you haven't done this already
big dog you you have to talk to her your
girl about it frankly tell her your
feelings and ask her about her own if
she she might even say something that
might even put your mind at ease and
it's like actually it's like this and
you think about it like a different way
it might even make you feel differently
about it talk to her about it she'll
understand if you're she already knows
you for four years she's not going to be
like whoa where's this coming from
you're never like this she already knows
you're a big dog right you know yeah
definitely talk to her about it if you
haven't done it yet yeah that's step one
but even if you have talked to her about
it like talk to her
about it in a in a different way this
time and just be like look it's it's too
much for me at this point and I want to
talk to you about figuring out a way to
help me deal with this is it me talking
to your brother is it you talking to
your brother is it all three of us
having a conversation I don't want it to
be as you know I I want to minimize the
potential sensitive reactions by your
family but like I'm totally down to be
as you know direct about it as I can be
but I don't want to overstep anything
that's going to make you feel
uncomfortable cuz obviously and this is
you to her like you're the most
important person in this situation to me
I want to make sure anything I do is
okay with you and it's all good that's
weird the whole thing is kind of weird
you know I none of it would bother me
until the that phone call then I would
be like all right so so I agree with you
what phone
call that that the brother got mad oh
right and the dad called it's like it's
so iMed and the I know was like on the
brother's side or like I don't know what
to tell you but your brother's mad and I
don't I don't know that's different you
know Dad was like look why didn't you
call you should have said goodbye to
your brother now he's upset and it
ruined his day like in mesh oh you guys
are [__] babies dud and mashman
babies you're all babies yep how's the
mom feel too uh like the last episode
you're all babies find a big crib big
dog needs to find a big crib and fit the
entire family in into that Big crib okay
well there have and then close the top
of it so they can't climb out big dog
here oh big dog I forgot to mention
completely in the first submission that
I've talked to my girlfriend multiple
times about her brother and as much as
it pisses me off more importantly it
makes her so uncomfortable and whenever
she goes into a situation where she's
going to be in one of these interactions
um she just has ter so this was last
episode oh yeah okay we got so so this
guy big dog this is a huge Revelation it
could have been two episodes ago but he
said that he has a problem with how much
affection his fiance or girlfriend or
wife's uh uh brother how much affection
his brother shows her right how much
affection her own brother yes shows her
shows her and we were like well is that
their thing or whatever or like have you
talked to her about it so he's clearing
this up for us and saying it makes her
uncomfortable which we did not know that
we were not pry to that information we
didn't know that it made her
uncomfortable sure definitely tell us
you should dude look come on Big Dog you
look like my friend from high school
Matt Hannah and you should have you
should have told us this important
detail which is that your girlfriend
also [__] hates it yeah look big dog
big dog you don't come with us with a
little bit of information you want to be
big dog you want big dog you come a
whole [__] you come with with the
[__] dossier a proper big dog would
have told us the entire picture bring
the dossier all right all right so
anyway dossier big dog yeah anxiety and
doesn't know what to do and she was
actually the one seeking the advice and
I kind of dropped the ball with my
delivery on the whole thing making it
kind of seem like it was just my problem
um but yeah definitely she's
uncomfortable we're still seeking advice
we got a little bit of an update uh not
a full resolution yet but yesterday she
went and talked to her dad had the
awkward conversation um just kind of
seeking refuge in her dad uh saying what
she feels how it makes her uncomfortable
the things that she finds weird
the dad completely took the brother's
side and said that she shouldn't be
feeling this way she needs to get more
comfortable with it all because he loves
her more than anybody else in the whole
entire
world made it a little weirder on top of
that he pointed out that she is her
brother's phone
wallpaper bro just a picture of her it
gets weirder and weirder as the days go
on regardless we're about 2 days away
from Thanksgiving and I think I'm gonna
have to just sack up and pull him to the
sideline and give him a Stern talking to
because at this point she's really
expressing that it makes her really
uncomfortable and she doesn't want to be
in these situations regardless I just
wanted to clear that up a little bit um
but love you guys between the last
submission and this submission I watched
the special 10 out of 10 some of your
best work yet thank you bro I'll call
you next week with an update and we'll
see what's going on dude we would love
life rips yeah buddy we would love an
update this is really interesting but it
was like and at the end the dad wanted
to give her a massage dude I don't it's
it's twisted at this point if the dad is
like you got to be okay with this little
girly like little like little girly you
got to be okay with the how much the
brother loves you so demented D little
girl you got to be okay with brother
basically what he said though dude dude
that is not cool man hold on hold on
let's look at this from a different lens
okay I agree it's very weird and needs
to stop okay but the father could just
be what dude you know Old-Timers and
[__] they're like I don't want there to
be a problem look just just it's your
brother relax you know what I'm saying
it's still bad but he needs to respect
how she feels but you know oldtimers bro
Old-Timers are like hey it's fine how's
the weather you know it could be a
little of that okay but if I'm if I'm
the dad mhm and my daughter comes to me
and says your son my brother is making
me uncomfortable with how touchy Fey he
is with me and like possessive he is of
me uh when I I see him it makes me
uncomfortable the very first thing I do
knock knock her out is oh no oh yeah is
roundhouse sweep her legs so she falls
on her [__] ass and says never talk
about family like that again no I would
call
him right and say hey man what's this
I'm heing like what what why are you
making your sister uncomfortable what
the [__] are you doing yeah or have him
talk to you both yeah be like hey guys
gather around what's going on here it's
like a it's like the thing about it is
it's a physical [__] up physical thing
like that is a no no dude you can't be
doing that [__] and it doesn't even
matter if the even if I don't believe
this but even if she was being what one
might call like over sensitive that
doesn't matter either you're making
someone uncomfortable you have to stop
doing that right for the dad to take the
brother's side to me is [__] demen
well here's the deal it's this is going
to end up in a Hulu documentary and you
know it is it's going to end up in a
Hulu Hulu DOI series Hulu you know Hulu
do series then and somebody's going to
die and it sucks and it's going to be
like a family secrets and all the way
back then it's going to have old oldtime
pictures of the dad you know what I mean
and you're [__] so so just make sure
you get a good deal from Hulu basically
is what I'm
saying yeah and if they make a movie
Hopefully the guy from reer can play you
you know that guy's pretty cool you know
you look like him a little bit uh but
yeah Big Dog's got to be big dog and and
step I'm sure you said something at
Thanksgiving so let us know how let us
know dude also hilarious to C big dog
and have a [__] framed picture of a
lion yeah we I think we know a a lot
about this guy at this point and that's
the and and just by the way bud that's
the worst picture you can have in your
house so anyway really really really
dumb buddy thing to have framed on your
wall in your home and and listen buddy
it's all good and even if it may not be
framed I don't know I may I saw it wrong
either way it's wor possible thing so
and that's fine big dog but uh it's all
good he's just a lion dude just a line
like in Shadows you know blacked out
behind it
just you know Big Dog hey big dog here
big cat behind me anyway um he's into
big [__] animals dude that's it yeah
this is a [__] zebra in his kitchen
there a big zebra here it's all smelly
and [__]